welcome to this video playing Romania
that's a grandmaster what is this for
like I can build you or something like
that North Korea okay oh this name Jill
papas scheme this is a Grand Master Zhu
purple team okay played him two times
for one draw upgrade don't think the sky
is living in North Korea okay so let's
see um yeah I'm okay this is um this is
what i play mostly this again just I
keep forgetting really if to to to to
check this line Night h2 is the normal
response but there is some very strange
some very strange piece sacrifice line
that I keep forgetting to check okay
let's see what what's happening here 6 I
think there's also this one and then we
should be too I'm probably miss mixing
up things here okay let's see if I go
Bishop here I can do that
just when you think you have prevented
the move that is played anyway okay it's
this the PSAC line I verily I mean f5
just looks like a total blunder because
GF is not possible and if taking with
the piece this G for winning a piece
young but he just blended this I can't
believe it okay there wasn't any special
thing connected to it okay all night c5
night be form might be tricky because of
the thread on c2 should be three maybe
our he can take we can take h3 I can
take h3 but I couldn't really do them I
mean I needed to move this I think we
should be three if he takes on age 3
i've got Knight f3 knight h4 maybe that
shouldn't be too bad the question is do
I have anything better I like G for
stuff like that I don't think so ok
let's um go ahead with this that's not
too bad i mean the bishop does not have
great squares available it probably
needs to go back to the seven may I
don't care to g4 but not sure that this
is doing anything great ok the question
is what's now night age for or is this
really not leading to much
generates fry is going to f7 no it's not
it's not particularly great now g5 286
could be an idea i mean i'm unsure very
complicated position
jia 196 you just take it you should do
through this eform so let's play and
move to prepare long castles it also
takes a look at age 60 after age 696 the
h6 pawn is directly hanging you're going
to need to get the King out of this to
have the a1 look plain yeah that's not a
very difficult position to play maybe
something like 94 is interesting for
black yeah that could be a move I mean I
can take on g4 and take on h7 but I have
weakened my light squares enormously not
g4 could be interesting okay and that's
also interesting I can take here now but
okay I need to do this son long run okay
so maybe pile up here I cannot really
ever take on c5 my bishop only three
years the piece that somehow ties the
whole position together covering f2
allowing the ship deform at the right
moment covering g5 and rock edge for a
useful to control a g4 may be attacking
e4 at the right moment yeah that looks
okay generally want them to play h6 at
some point to allow 96 and then the
capture on h6 breaking through yeah it's
a good sign I'm that I'm catching up on
the clock a bit okay five interesting so
mm-hmm if I go g4 hmm not sure g4 I can
take maybe can take with an idea
my ticket oh of course always take with
the bishop we are very tricky maybe
maybe this night to edge then to f4
looks like a very very positional idea
but maybe it sets okay only took me very
long that's not good 94 maybe i will
this way yeah i can take age 5 now i can
take III look everyone check and high
morning that's somewhat annoying but
long i need to do it probably it's a
matter of time also i can take on c3 but
then ok then i have b to as an escape
square it looks somewhat fishy rookie
three maybe yeah here we go check ok now
here and night f2 wow ok there any way
to to save this
see any move not really seeing a move
our kid the Lucas thing I thought Queen
g2 but ok this didn't work yeah 92 he
can play 92 amongst others I mean but ok
let's sir let's play this out check yeah
okay why this is a really tricky I mean
okay this is very weird that he played
at five and after EF just retreated when
really looks like he just blundered this
but it wasn't it wasn't so terrible
funny enough but ok I don't take ya now
there is this night night before
business which looks a bit bitter dug a
bit of a problem ok I see brother
computers of course very strong here
Knight f3 it once the plane that's
really strong guy on I understand the
problem is i'm going night h4 here and
something like that I still go here and
this is simply not working because now I
win this piece the the Queen has no
square to go to wear it Kelsey to so
that this renders night before is
completely useless after night h4 you
need to basically retreat him and then I
just sent the night back and this is a
position where why this almost winning
because I have the pawn already and the
night on h4 is controlling the super
important at five squares is just very
bad
so that was the refutation of this this
display I didn't really see that so I
went here and now it's a it's I don't
know I still would say white should be
better but it's it's very very tricky
maybe knowledge floors better I don't
know it's very complicated stuff
generally I cannot really tell what was
going on I could have taken these three
but this just looked okay but h5 maybe I
really need to play f3 here I mean I
consider this briefly to cover really
cover those two critical squares f3 the
problem of it is that it after f3 this
piece is so loose it looks like i don't
know there is something let's say this
this type of idea can be a problem
lining up here that's a bit of a
stretcher all this and is also false so
this one is legitly diagonal and this is
why I didn't I didn't want to play a 3
and went here this was after some some
thought I really couldn't find a move
that completely satisfied me maybe I
must do this this f3 business yeah seems
very unclear but this this was not
really working 94 was stronger no I'm
and really a bit bitter olive moves yeah
black is winning here the computers on
man minus 3 so night 83 was dad looks
strategically nice but it just fails due
to concrete concrete reasons it's very
complicated very complicated position
yeah ok hope you enjoyed it thanks for
watching